the best thing about doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness might be the
crazy fan service but don't get too
excited it's kind of the worst thing
about the movie too from the comic
cameos to bruce campbell these are the
best and worst things in doctor strange
2 warning spoilers ahead
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness introduced a key new character
to the marvel cinematic universe in the
form of america chavez a gifted young
woman played by sochi gomez america's
role in the story is essentially that of
a living plot device since her ability
to punch open portals between universes
makes her a valuable asset to the
scarlet witch with that in mind america
spends much of the film on the run
struggling to control her power while
trying to escape the scarlet witch
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
the character and gomez is definitely a
charming capable actress with a lot to
contribute to the wider mcu if you've
read america's comic book appearances
though particularly in recent years you
know that she's a character with
considerably more swagger and confidence
than she gets in the film the comics
version of america would be much more
likely to fight back and while we can
dismiss the difference as the need to
portray the mcu version as a superhero
beginner it still comes across as a
little jarring hopefully future
appearances of the character will give
her a little more of her comic book
personality
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is the first superhero film in
more than a decade to be directed by sam
raimi he's the energetic filmmaker
behind the original spider-man trilogy
he's also a lifelong comic book fan
whose exuberance for the genre seeps
through onto the screen raymie's
involvement was reason enough for even
non-mcu fans to get excited about the
new film and it was clear even from the
opening sequence that raimi came to play
though there's been no shortage of
interesting filmmakers working in the
mcu over the years multiverse of madness
might just be the most visually exciting
film marvel studios has released in at
least half a decade it might not be able
to match the scale of something like
avengers end game or the comic chops of
thor ragnarok but the sheer force of
raimi's visual creativity sets it apart
from other films in this franchise it's
a movie we're going to be looking at
shot by shot for years to come
one of the more intriguing supporting
characters confirmed early on for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
was carl mordo steven strange's teacher
turned rival sorcerer played by chuatel
ejiofor the character had not been seen
since his turn to the darker side of
things at the end of the first doctor
strange movie so his appearance in the
sequel seemed to suggest we'd get a
chance to see what he's been up to since
sadly the version of mordo that we see
in multiverse of madness is actually a
version of the character from an
alternate universe and while he's
antagonistic towards strange he's not
the same kind of antagonist we were
expecting from the post-credits scene in
the original film i'm sorry steven the
film doesn't have the time or space to
give us the original flavor of mordo and
when it gives us a fight between the two
sorcerers the alternate reality mordo
ends up trapped in a shallow trench
shouting it strange rather than fighting
on ej4 is as always up to whatever
acting task he's given but it felt like
an underwhelming return for an
interesting character
from the moment multiverse of madness
was announced marvel studios head and
producer kevin feige promised the film
would integrate horror elements into the
marvel cinematic universe in ways we'd
never seen before now that the film is
here it's clear that he made good on
that promise the first doctor strange
film directed by sinister helmer scott
derrickson certainly featured its share
of creepy elements but multiverse of
madness pushes all of that just a little
further it begins with the decision to
make the scarlet witch into a full-on
movie monster complete with jump scares
and creepy body movements it continues
into the film's wild finale which
features doctor strange possessing his
own corpse from another universe and
creating a flying cloak out of the souls
of the damned it's not the scariest
movie you're ever going to see but for a
superhero film in one of the most mass
appeal based franchises ever it's
definitely packing more than a few
frightening moments which is rather
refreshing
fan service is an inevitable part of the
marvel cinematic universe and there's
nothing wrong with that whether we're
talking about the days of the earliest
stan lee cameos or the merging of three
different spider-man timelines into one
movie experience there's real value in
getting audiences excited about familiar
things they can cheer about that said
there's a point where it runs out of
steam and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness ultimately hits
that point the scene in which steven
strange meets the superhero group the
illuminati from another universe is
packed with fan service and big
cheer-worthy cameos unfortunately
despite its importance to the film's
overall plot it sometimes plays more
like a roll call than an actual piece of
dialogue between various major
characters by the time all the
characters pause their arguing to allow
charles xavier to dramatically roll in
from the other room it's clear that the
scene's first priority is packing in the
cameos and while that's fun
it's also clumsy there had to be a
smoother way to pull all of this off
long time marvel cinematic universe
viewers are used to fanservice at this
point the people behind these films know
that their fans aren't just watching
them for the story they're looking out
for all the easter eggs cameos and hints
of things to come and so they're ready
to pack as much of that content as they
can into each film and yes that can get
tiresome sometimes and in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness there are
moments when it feels like it honestly
does even with that in mind it's hard to
deny the raw endorphin buzz that many of
these moments can generate when they
roll out just right sure some of it can
feel excessive but hearing the smartest
man in the world reed richards of the
fantastic four is enough to send a chill
down your spine even if it is a payoff
of years of internet fan casting more
than an actual character moment plus no
matter how you feel about his present or
future involvement in the mcu hearing
the theme from x-men the animated series
worked into charles xavier's
introduction is one of the coolest
flourishes the mcu has ever pulled off
so yes fan service can be rough but it
can also still work really well
superhero movies are not and have never
been exercises in 100 realism and we
don't just mean in terms of people
flying around shooting energy out of
their hands there's a sense of
heightened reality to every aspect of
these films which means you have to
suspend your disbelief a little bit when
someone needs to make a rousing speech
or take a moment in the middle of a big
fight to have an outburst of emotion
it's just part of the game that said
there are times when that suspension of
disbelief is tested and doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness has a few
of them that stand out many issues can
be traced to seemingly small character
decisions that end up being very
noticeable the film sets the scarlet
witch up as this unstoppable force of
terror then shows us characters who are
waiting behind doors they already know
she can break through as though they're
suddenly safe it gives us characters
who've just seen how hard they need to
fight to survive moving far too slowly
attacking wanda one at a time and it
even pauses for a moment of high drama
when strange finally gets to the book of
ashanti when the narrative has already
proven there's no time to waste again
these are small moments but in an
otherwise well-paced film they stand out
elizabeth olsen has always been a
formidable actor and sticking around the
mcu so long has allowed her to show off
just how much emotional weight she can
add to a superhero story we saw it most
prominently with her show one division
but she doesn't let any of that power
lapse by the time multiverse of madness
rolls around if anything she deepens and
darkens it you break the rules and
become a hero
i do it and i become the enemy this time
olson gets to play not just wanda a
frightened traumatized sad woman just
trying to make it through the day but
also scarlet witch a determined and
relentless magic user who is convinced
she's doing the right thing even when
slaughtering innocent people olsen's
ability to pivot between those
performances on a dime and in some
scenes even played both of them at the
same time is one of the film's greatest
assets she's capable of being both
deeply vulnerable and flat-out
terrifying which deepens the emotion
behind the entire film's arc and makes
us hope she gets to stick around for
more adventures
the marvel cinematic universe is packed
with characters and the finite run time
of movies means that some of those
characters are going to fall by the
wayside over the course of certain
adventures multiverse of madness is a
doctor strange movie but it also has to
make room for plenty of screen time for
the scarlet witch alternate versions of
doctor strange america chavez and more
that means that other characters get
pushed to the back more than they should
and unfortunately wang is a victim of
that in this film to its detriment
played by benedict wong long is one of
the great supporting characters in the
mcu
try not to slip we don't have liability
insurance
he's charming he's funny he has great
chemistry with steven strange and the
universe has rewarded him by making him
the current sorcerer supreme and a key
part of the magical corner of this
overarching story and yet despite a few
scene-stealing moments wong spends a
huge chunk of the film either in silent
captivity or knocked unconscious waiting
for the opportune time to show up and
help save the day again there's only so
much time to give each character in a
movie but long feels like he just got
short shrift hopefully future films can
rectify that
any long time fan of sam remy knows that
the director has
certain hallmarks there's the mixing of
humor and horror the clever transition
work the dynamic moving camera and of
course the involvement of bruce campbell
since coming up in the film business
with raymie and starring in the
director's breakthrough film the evil
dead campbell has continued to make
cameo appearances of various sizes
throughout the raimi filmography when
raymie was confirmed to make doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
fans hoped they'd see campbell pop up
and weren't disappointed it takes a
little while for campbell's cameo to
take shape but raymie makes a count
casting his old friend as the
unsuspecting gruff owner of a pizza ball
stand in an alternate universe who
demands america chavez pay for her food
doctor strange intervenes and casts a
spell on the man that makes him beat
himself up for three weeks it's a great
physical comedy showcase for campbell
and it pays off one more time in the
film's post-credits scene it's a small
part of the film but always a delight
when campbell gets some screen time
the key dramatic push-pull of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
falls on the continuing saga of wanda
maximoff the star of one division who is
still having a hard time dealing with
the fallout from the events of that
series wanda despite her growth and
knowledge still misses her family
deeply and all the time she spent
studying the darkhold has turned into a
full-on yearning for change she emerges
as the key antagonist of the film when
it's clear that the scarlet witch
persona has overtaken her more
reasonable side and that she's willing
to get an alternate version of her kids
to be with her no matter the cost by the
end of the film of course wanda sees the
error of her ways and realizes that the
pursuit of her children has made her a
monster she decides to destroy the
darkhold in all its forms and in the
process brings a mountain temple down
around herself seemingly killing her of
course anyone who follows comic book
storytelling knows that this probably
isn't actually the end for wanda so why
make it ambiguous at all why not just
show us wanda maximoff either truly
dying in an act of sacrifice or going
off into seclusion again to find her way
into the world anew it feels more like a
setup than an honest ending to a
satisfying arc and that's a shame
the marvel cinematic universe is an
increasingly vast landscape of
characters locations situations and
conflicts which means sometimes the
stories can get so bogged down in
keeping up with continuity that they
have a hard time establishing any real
emotional resonance yes it's cool to
spend an entire film talking about
various superheroes but at a certain
point you still want to be reminded why
you care about them as people doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
certainly has its share of major
exposition but writer michael waldron
takes all the talent he displayed
writing the disney plus series loki and
pours it into the characters along the
way we understand why wanda maximoff is
still struggling so much and why she's
willing to give in to the power of the
scarlet witch we understand why steven
strange is at an emotional crossroads in
his life and has difficulty being truly
happy despite his immense power and
influence we even understand thanks to
one particularly important piece of
backstory why strange is such a control
freak to begin with and why he has a
hard time forming attachments with
people it's an effectively structured
well-paced story that knows exactly when
to let the heart shine through check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the marvel
cinematic universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]